今日はドクターはじめと8つです
阿部勇樹ですね我々今どこにいくっているかといいますと
出身の富山下に来ておりマーヤさーん
あー同列はい何か思うことはないか x ああああ cache 人があんまりない
ですね
アドほらファーンみろあシャッターだらけだシャッターげだ
素直に表すと
寂しいですねココアの魚津市っていう街なんですけども
我々富山県出身のものとしてそうですねこの夏を盛り上げるために何かできないかと
考えたところ
魚座子さんの協力もいただいてですねこの像店外である
シャッターにこの松岡毅付けさせるような素敵な絵を書いていきたいとおもいます
人を惹きつける素敵なイラストをか
ブーブー
あったけど手伝ってくださる解説の方ですよろしくねします
いや早速作戦か言うといきましょう入っ
そうです
女って確かに名刺
レールに
[音楽]
マッサージからって言っ
相手上で作成会議が終わりましたそれで美術部の人と連携してもうちょっと part
皆さんかけ始めてもらっていますまずは一枚目変えていきましょう
います
ねむずに行くのが止めこえーよ寿司の判定を祈って書かせていただきます
あーこれやばいバッハこれらはリブですねっ
頃シャッターのもちろんしまうとザク重が受けた愛者が流れ
ma 何をころです本当にいやマジです
大きかったり怒られ御旅こんなたです
ブーバーしっある日あっ始めちゃっ分かりあー初めてこんにちはー
僕の本名ですかっどう付く名前大丈夫ですねこれ会10日
いいんでしょあー汚れを掲げられるんだ回転体恐怖だぞ
[音楽]
入ったけど2枚目でございます大津市といえば
ホタルイカみたいなところがあるって壁にちょっとたくさん書ければいいなと思います
配布楽しく泳いでる感情音出していきたい
羞恥方がえええっ
このこれが猛威の違いは取ってますやっぱ0
地元普通の塩代表としてやっぱり僕はこの街を誓いなお近い直井
開いてあげでえっと僕たちが担当さところはもうカーテンしたんですけれども
他の美術の花と竜の部分もちょっと見て行きたいと思いますはい
心はぁっはぁっはぁっ
とだぞのセンターでございますすっごい
もやりん
指よろしくお願います次ができて結構もう街の中心的な不運なんで結構色んな人に見
られる場所の絵を見ていきましょう
どんなシャッターになっているんでしょうか
うわあああああ
雪 yahoo うわぁ凄い
アーマー4つ目でございますこれめっちゃ嬉しい上に良かったね
行くああそうーーあそぼ
それはいつも目指す青鬼は和美サザンのスライムの丘せれば0俺もう
ああああ
目立つあーんですっ
いやーだよわぁ嬉しいわわずすごい
いやこれ酸っぱいな心ここで見たときの音
一発がーはいというわけでも日が暮れてきたので1部終了でございます
カラーですまだねカーテンしなかったり一ページ目で的なとグーッとある女性ちゃった
兄
絵を書いていこうと思いますはい4つははいもう嫌になったのでなんですけどさっき
予定があって絵を一時目て帰ってしまいます今瀬たらいいよいいよ
おはようございますし掴みでございますというわけで4つがいなくなったんですけども
今日は1人+位
美術部の方と頑張って行きたいと思いますで札ですね
天気がすごい悪いんです今日元気出るのにはちょっと大変なんですけどちょうど最終皆
で頑張っていきたいとおもいます
いよいよ所内でまず最初の僕の仕事はその後のへたー
しゃべってる部分を書こうと思います
空いてるで小型分完成だと思いますトマトのヘタが魚津市に行って触れたあなたを
web 買うと歓迎しております
はい tv で次のシャッターでございますこちらに書いていこうと思いますあぁもう
と地元紙がつかないことになってしまいました
[音楽]
4 o
今じゃあなぜ土曜会でいい
混ざりますこの芸術的なポイント夏のおばけがバーンを持つなら泉本を言っている
この絵だけで3種類の食べ物は礼装されてこれは見たい人の脳内はきっとバージョン
するはずです
[音楽]
ん
お気ですかいつ指で宿願かけて計8枚のシャッターと書き終わりました
celstore ません
相次ぎでもう全部関連したので早速しちゃった後を見ていきましょう
どうぞ
[音楽]
ni
入っトイレですね今回こんな感じでシャッター以来にシャッターぶっかけまくるって
言う可能ですねあの日本ダイバーさんとの取組で
させていただきました今起きている問題をほっておくともう治らないことあるかもしれ
ないんで俺たちとか皆さんをやるしかないんですよ
こういうことは本当にシャッター最も結構社会問題になってて
学校
米外にも買えばいいなとって僕行ったんですけども是非皆さんもこの動画を見て何か
自分でできることはあったらなーとか考えてくれるだけでも嬉しいです
魚津にもシャッターと見に来てくれるのは嬉しいんだけども
俺の去った後に落書きするんだよ
me
あっはぁ